welcome everybody my name is Adam DC I'm
Adam DC dev on Twitter and before I was
a software engineer I attended school
for music specifically music composition
and I was always drawn to the analytical
thinking aspect of music theory and
years later when I started to learn
functional programming I found that that
kind of the same itch was scratched
so when I started a musical project with
web development I decided to use
functional programming so here's my
introduction to functional programming
from a musical perspective so first we
have to ask the question what is
functional programming
well it's programming with functions I
just like object-oriented is based
around objects functions are the
building blocks so that leads the next
question what is a function well a non
functional definition might be something
like a sequence of commands attracted
into a reusable unit but a functional
definition is more something like a
relationship between a set of inputs and
outputs this is the mathematical
definition of of a function and is
sometimes referred to in programming as
a pure function so what makes a function
pure first means given the same
arguments in it will return the same
value this this means that it shouldn't
rely on anything from the outside such
as a random number generator the current
time or a read from the database it also
means no side-effects
this means it shouldn't affect anything
outside of itself it shouldn't many play
the Dom or write to the database or play
music and sometimes this is referred to
as being referentially transparent and
referentially transparent means that the
function and its arguments can be
replaced by its return value so for an
example we are here defining a note it
has a name
and an octave for here we have a pure
function increment octave it accepts a
note and returns a new note with octave
incremented by one pi see here is the
result of that pure function play here
is an impure function because it has a
side-effect
it plays music and here you can note
that you can pass in either high C or
increment octave middle C and have the
same effect this is where the
referential transparency comes in so you
learn functional programming and you
move all side effects and now your
program is useless it's important to
note that side effects are not bad they
include making an HTTP request
manipulating the Dom putting the console
or playing music side effects are not
bad but they are unpredictable and they
are harder to test so you should use
your impure functions carefully and
predictably alright now that we have a
definition of functional programming
here are some of the tools that are
important immutability immutability is
the idea that variable state cannot be
modified after its creation
you might be thinking something like why
why would you like to why would you
limit yourself by tying one hand behind
your back but there is a reason for for
this one of the advantages is that is
less for your brain to track humans have
a working memory it's kind of like the
biological equivalent to RAM you can
only keep track of so many things at a
time so by making sure not to change
your variables let's Lester a brain to
track it also prevents unintentional
side-effects trust me I know from
experience that accidentally changing a
variable and function could be a really
hard bug to track down immutability also
preserves state think about like a bank
account it doesn't just show your
balance it shows your starting balance
and then all of your withdrawals and
deposits I higher-order functions are
functions that either accept a function
as an argument or return a new function
so you might be thinking something like
this here's a
here's an example so we've got tone J s
is a framework on top of the Web Audio
API the Web Audio API itself is very low
level and and maybe a little more than
what you need so the the the Web Audio
API helps abstract it become a little
easier play note here is a higher order
function it accepts a note and it
returns a new function play middle C
here is the result of play note and it
is the new function add event listener
here accepts a function as an argument
so add event listener and played-out are
both higher-order play note because it
returns a function and add event
listener him because it accepts a
function so here's our first beautiful
musical example I promise they get a
little better from here on out I dealing
with arrays manipulating arrays are an
important part of all paradigms and
JavaScript comes with some array methods
that work really well with functional
programming and there are two concepts
that we covered that that are important
to dealing with arrays there's
higher-order functions each of these
methods except a function and
immutability because each of the ment
mentioned methods here will return a new
array so array dot filter right up
filter accepts a function that's run
against every element it receives an
element index and array and it returns a
subset of the original array so here
we're defining the melody is high here
compares and the nose frequency in Hertz
to middle C and if the provider note is
C for or above it will return true
otherwise it will return false so we
passed the is high function into the
melody filter and we get the only the
values that remain so here we have an
unfiltered melody
[Music]
and when we remove all the notes that
are that are that don't pass the is hi
[Music]
we have the new melody a write up map is
similar it accepts a function that's run
against every element and receives the
element index and array but rather than
checking if a value is truthy or faulty
it returns an array of the same length
as the original but with new values so
here we have a melody and we have our
increment octave function from before it
takes a note and it returns a new note
and we can map the notes with this
increment octave function then we have
the same melody but each notes octave
has been incremented
[Music]
now we have a radar produced a radar
reduce is a little bit more complicated
it accepts a function that's run against
every every element but in addition to
the element index and array it also
receives an accumulator and returns an
accumulated value this is also known as
fold or accumulate in some languages and
it is a more generic tool than filter or
map I sometimes hear that radar reduced
takes an array and it returns a single
value this is true but I don't find it
to be a particularly useful distinction
because all functions in JavaScript will
return a single value so I like to think
of array dot reduced as a value that
takes an array and it can return any
type filter for example will take an
array and it will return a new array
that is of smaller size array that map
will take an array and it will return a
new array of the same length both with
different values a rate not reduce can
return anything whether it be a number
or a string or an array filter and map
for example can be written in reduce so
here's here's an example we have a
little bit longer melody we define the
notes and the length here we have a two
length function that's going to be
passed to reduce total here is the
accumulator and note here is the array
element the method here accepts the
function two length and an initial value
and it will return the end accumulation
so we start with the initial value of
zero and then we add it to each to each
note length so zero plus point one two
five plus point one two five is 0.25
point three seven five and so on until
we get to the overall melodies length so
here didn't update the timer supposed to
go up on my screen says one point six
two five
partial application personal application
is an incredibly useful tool for writing
reusable and generic functions and
partial application works by pre setting
or fixing some of the arguments to a
function so here we've got the transpose
function it takes a direction an
interval and a note and it returns a new
note so here up nature third is a
partially apply transpose it accepts a
note and it calls transpose with up and
a major third preset so here we can
convert c4 to e4 or b-flat - to d3 and
partial application is currently in
stage one of the tc39 proposal and if
that goes through then you'll be able to
use the question mark to partially apply
function so here are down minor seventh
is a partially apply transpose as well
so you don't have to manually apply it
hard code each of the functions so here
we can map using array to map these
partial applied functions to an array of
notes
[Music]
which I could take credit for that
melody here's it Maps it down a minor
70s alright composition composition I
find to really be the bread and butter a
functional programming and composition
is a technique to combine multiple
functions into a new function so here
we're going to take a note name and
we'll return a slightly detuned
frequency first we have a function
converting a note name to a frequency
for example an input of a4 would which
is a note name of a and an octave a4
will return 440 that's the the Hertz of
that note and here we're defining
function to multiply by small percentage
so once we have that frequency we can
detune it so in input a 440 would return
444 0.4 so compose takes two new
functions and calls them from right to
left the right to left is because
compose is a mathematical concept and
compose reads them from right to left if
you are you can use pike which is a
similar idea but from left to right and
we'll be looking at that a little bit
later so here get deep get d2 dn't
frequency is a new composition that
takes an input and it passes it first to
frequency and then to detune up so an
input of a four will return 444 0.4 so
passing through the 440 value and the
pipeline operator is also in the stage 1
of tc39 and it would also allow for easy
function composition allow you the pipe
of value through multiple functions here
we got our a for our detuned a form all
right putting it all together I promised
we'd be composing music with composed
functions well here we're gonna be
writing a function that converts a
human-readable shorthand into a computer
readable array alright so can everybody
read this alright so don't don't worry I
will zoom in on the important parts
first we're gonna be importing some
dependencies from Ram de and tan Jaya
Ram de is a utility library similar to
lodash or underscores but with a more
functional approach and you might note
that there are a lot of functions I'm
importing one of the cool things about
functional programming is that you take
lots of small functions and combine them
together with composition so for example
parse name here is a function it takes a
shorthand note and it returns the name
so c4 at a 10 would be a string where
the C is the note name the fours are
octave in the 8 n is the duration so
pipes through first to this regex
and that will return an array of
matching strings so any valid note name
and then it takes a head to return just
the full string so when passing in c4 at
a 10 the match function will return an
array of C and then head function will
take that and return just C so C for a
day 10 becomes array of the string c2
just the string seed parse octave is
similar imagines it to digits and then
we convert it to a number and parse
duration similarly will split at the at
symbol and it will take the last so c4
at a 10 will bring an array of c4 comma
a 10 and then just a 10 first time here
is a little bit more complicated it
takes a note and its context and it
returns a scheduled time so here we have
the array of notes we're slicing it to
only those preceding in and then we map
each of those to their length and we
reduce those to a single value and
overall this lets the Web Audio API know
when to play each note you're taking the
duration of all the notes before an
individual note and you're taking the
direction of them all and adding them
together and that lets you know when to
play the new note
so here parse shorthand is a composition
of compositions where it accepts a
string and it will return an array of
note objects so first it splits at all
whitespace converting a string
to an array of strings and an array map
here works like the array da map but as
a function so that allows us to pipe
into it and apply spec here takes an
object shape with functions each string
in the in the array that we just split
will be passed into each of these
functions and it will be mapped to an
object of the same shape so the string
will be passed a parse name and that'll
be the value for the key name the string
we passed a part octave they'll be the
value for the key octave and so on so
overall with our purse shorthand
function which takes an array of strings
this input string will be split at
whitespace become this array of strings
which will become this array of note
objects as that allows us to convert
this into this or we can convert this
into this
[Music]
[Applause]
again I wish I could take credit for
those melodies but so why do you want to
use functional programming I've heard
that it allows for easier easier reason
ability easier debugging easier testing
for me I find that functional
programming is really nice because it
forces you to break down problems into
their smallest parts and by taking those
small parts you can combine the tiny
solutions into larger solutions so if
you found this interesting and would
like to go further a few great resources
I would highly suggest professor
frisbees mostly adequate guide to
functional programming it's it's a great
book available online for free it goes
very in-depth into functional
programming also I would suggest is
looking into functional utility
libraries looking into their functions
Ramba is the one that I used here lo -
FB is a similar uses similar functional
techniques but with but is based on low
- so if you're familiar with low - that
that might be a better fit and just
looking at these and asking yourself
when might you use this function I found
really is a great way to level up and
also lambda cast is a great podcast for
for all things functional programming
thank you so much if you have any
questions
catch me afterwards or message me at
Adam GC dev and the slides are available
at compos'd
Adam GC calm thank you
[Applause]
[Music]